This video is brought to you by
brilliant.org.
Hey wisecrack.
It's brainy.
Jared here,
Helen,
and today we're talking about the first
season of one of the most cerebral
enemies out there.
Psychopaths tonight,
not just cut a when you kiddish data,
so no,
she still sick and each coteau auto to
go to her daycare.
What about yours?
Is the digital economy in?
Yeah,
they're talking to each other by quoting
philosophy and it's amazing.
Set in a dystopian Japan where
everything is controlled by a seemingly
omniscient computer.
The civil system,
psychopaths asked some pretty hefty
questions.
Mainly,
is it possible for a computer to
determine everything about us?
Does she could see it so she didn't get
a sick guy just against this,
and more importantly,
would we want to live in a society
without freewill?
I don't cook with.
Does she get out?
She didn't know that well,
as it happens,
this question isn't just about
philosophy,
but also science.
So sit down,
shut up and let disembodied.
Helen,
explain how the civil system just might
suggest that freewill is a neurological
and societal illusion in this wise crack
addition on the science and philosophy
of psychopaths and cues.
Sirens.
That's what we do with spoilers,
right?
Also covering all the sexy smart stuff
in this series would be impossible to do
in one video,
so if you want to hear jared break it
down some more,
let us know in the comments.
First,
a quick recap.
For the uninitiated.
In the world of psychopaths,
the civil system determines everything
about you from your job to the
likelihood that you'll commit a crime
all by constantly scanning your brain
and keeping you under surveillance.
This handy Dandy all encompassing
reading is called your psychopaths and
it's what the civil system uses to make
all these decisions about you
email system in your home that you knew.
Enter a Kanye soon,
amaury a Newbie inspector at the
Criminal Investigations Department or
CID.
It's kind of like being a cop,
except instead of following the law,
you're following the systems,
directions,
demo mother that she beat us.
You still couldn't,
and instead of police dogs,
you get enforcers who were basically
would be criminals that the system has
granted limited freedom to in exchange
for.
Well not a lot.
You might think that a legal system
based off a computer scanning your brain
is some minority report level bull.
You have free will so you shouldn't be
arrested before you actually commit a
crime.
Right?
Well,
let me stop you right there.
As psychopaths illustrates,
it's not quite that simple.
First,
we have to understand what the brain and
the decision making process really is.
Most neuroscientists today think there
are two systems in the brain.
The first system is us.
That little voice in our heads,
those emotions,
we feel all those thoughts.
We think it's the stuff we're actually
aware of when we make a decision.
This is the system where we like to
think it happens,
but that's not entirely the case.
Below this system is another system,
a huge lattice work of neurons that
controls everything from spatial
processing to breathing.
Importantly,
this second system is a black box.
No matter how much armchair
philosophizing we do,
we can't penetrate it,
and this is where the science of free
will comes in.
See,
in the 19 eighties,
Dr Benjamin Lavette conducted a pretty
groundbreaking experiment.
He asked subjects to look at a clock
then at a time of their own choosing,
flick the wrist labelle then recorded
the electrical impulses from their brain
called the readiness potential and
compared it with the time the subjects
believed they made the decision to flick
their wrist.
The results readiness potential
proceeded the subject's awareness of
making the decision by about half a
second.
In other words,
the decision to flick their wrist
happened somewhere in the unconscious
system about half a second before they
thought they made the decision.
Kind of like funder following lightning
and while labettes experiment wasn't
without flaws like how he relied on self
reporting,
it's important to note that other
researchers have borne out similar
results and experiments that were better
controlled when we can't say for sure
that there's a causal relationship here.
We can say that on some level it looks
like the decision making process begins
in this unconscious part of the brain,
which makes you wonder,
are we really completely in control of
the choices we make and if we're not,
how can we say their ours labettes
experiment goes a long way in making
sense of psychopaths is world.
After all,
why would anyone let a computer make a
preemptive judgments about them ordering
every facet of their lives?
Well,
because a very smart computer like the
civil system can have a deep
understanding of the brain's black box
in a sense knowing is better than we
know ourselves held.
The system knows the inner workings of
the unconscious mind so well that it can
even identify likely criminals as
toddlers,
both either cycle bus as she got a coco
and you do in a
sense the relationship between the civil
system and its citizens is parallel to
the relationship between the two systems
in our brain,
the citizens mole about with other
feelings,
thoughts,
and seeming choices while literally
thousands of feet below their feet is a
vast network of sensors,
processors,
and fiber optic cables.
All in charge of them,
but if our unconscious mind is affecting
our conscious decisions,
we have to wonder what then is affecting
our unconscious mind.
If we're here subliminal messages
saying,
Love Logan,
Paul,
are we actually going to like him?
Unsurprisingly,
the civil system takes the question of
what can affect its citizens minds very
seriously.
The system is practically obsessed with
keeping the mental states of its
citizenry,
squeaky clean,
so much so that it measures the stress
levels of public spaces constantly.
Imagine walking around the mall
peacefully,
minding your own business when you're
psychopaths reading changes and this guy
comes up to you with this obsession of
keeping its citizens healthy.
It's also not surprising that the system
will also black out the press for the
public good consumers and it goes
without saying that other forms of
expression like music and art are also
limited.
This is pretty much an Orwellian
nightmare of the first degree,
but as the simple system wrong to
control freedom of speech
because you're a to you guys to go with
you so you can join or
homelands handled.
Chibe,
does she still have some on some other,
as frightening as it may sound,
science at least might say no.
As it turns out,
human beings are world class imitators.
We're so good.
In fact,
that we do it innately without even
realizing it.
Research performed by Andrew Meltzoff
has shown that infants imitate even the
most ludicrous of actions.
Fourteen month olds,
for example,
we'll do dumped like use their foreheads
instead of their fingers to turn on the
touch sensor light simply by watching an
adult do it.
Now,
there's evidence to suggest that
children are such good imitators because
the parts of their brain that control
inhibition aren't fully developed,
but just because we're not wearing
diapers doesn't mean adults are any less
likely to imitate their peers.
In fact,
humans are so susceptible to imitation
it just perceiving an action performed
by another person will drastically
increase the likelihood of them
emulating it.
This is called the chameleon effect,
and it has to do with a special set of
brain cells called mirror neurons,
which fire when we watch others'
performance action.
This goes on during all of our
interactions without us ever noticing
it,
and that's the key takeaway.
It happens automatically and
subconsciously it happens in that
impenetrable system of our brain.
So why would the symbol system need to
crack down on crime before crime happens
because behavior is contagious and that
means everything from laughing to
violence and when we're exposed to the
ladder,
even in the regular world,
there are consequences,
and this seems to be the case in the
world of psychopaths.
When the city is flooded with low grade
criminals wearing helmets that stopped
the civil system from reading,
they're psychopaths.
We see violence spread to the normal
citizens within almost gleeful contagion
cycle.
Have a good one,
nosy,
go,
go to Korea.
Both ads about it.
They didn't know what hit them at the.
She was,
like I said,
I go to the shoot on bulk or Chico state
or
so.
Whether it's in your brain or on the
streets,
it's clear that the civil system is bent
on removing agency from its citizens.
She be done.
Okay.
Eight kids still as you want a night
sort of kids done three ish almost
today,
and this is where we get to the question
at the heart of psychopaths.
What is the value of living in a society
without freewill?
It's exactly this question that drives
showgirl Moxie map.
This first seasons antagonist maximized,
driven to test the value of freewill in
a society where it's been rendered,
meaningless
selling them.
I just don't know to Thomas,
he knew he needed community today.
Geeky stuff,
so no hunting touch you.
I know annual [inaudible] your needs in
Taco bell could still no Thomasina sort
of got home.
Tony told him I.
he's your typical Tomas.
Islam told us touching.
It cuts you out
in positing the necessity of freewill.
Mark Shimo borrows a page from wisecrack
favorite Emmanuel Kant,
who believes that you can only be moral
by following moral laws out of your own
free will and Moxie.
Mark goes to insane links to see the
worth of people's will.
Enabling criminal after criminal who
wants to test their will against the
system.
But Mark Shima is the batty.
So does that mean a believes?
The opposite is she the symbol systems
number one fan going all in for the
belief that freewill must be squashed
for the greater collective good.
Well,
not really.
Throughout the series a connie displays
a unique sense of individualism.
She was such a good student that the
system determined she'd be a good fit in
literally any industry.
So look,
get the.
And after she joined the CID,
a Conay early on questions the merit of
blindly following the civil systems
orders,
culminating with her disobeying her
bosses order to kill her enforcer,
Shinya Coca,
me,
Hon.
Xy cases that take your assignments.
And although she begrudgingly allows the
system to remain by the end of the first
season,
she does so on her own terms,
each that I see me.
Do you want me to get any city in this
sense?
Uh,
Connie represents a sort of middle
ground.
Sure.
Maybe the unconscious mind or the civil
system influences her decisions,
but ultimately they're still hers to
make despite reaffirming a system that
strips her of some agency.
Uh,
Connie herself manages to preserve the
semblance free will.
But in the end,
a con,
I can't actually stop mocks Yuma.
That role falls to Kokanee.
Now we could say a lot about why
Moctezuma values Koga me so much more
than a connie,
but I think it has to do with this by
letting the civil system dictate your
life.
Mcsema believes you stop becoming an
individual without free will.
You're not a human,
but merely a cog in the machine.
Maybe this is why.
Kogi,
the man who willing to live as a
fugitive from the system in order to
stop mock Cima is the only one mcsema
cares about.
By the seasons end.
Cogan may is the only one who acts
freely,
and in this sense,
he's the only one mock Shima has a real
relationship with in this world.
Both
what makes the world of psychopaths so
frightening is that unlike other shows,
this dystopian society isn't the result
of paranoia or crisis management,
but of scientific progress.
So what do you guys think is freewill,
all that great or even real,
or would we all be better off letting a
super computer called the shots?
Personally,
I've over free will and letting
computers only check email,
stay ahead,
brilliant dot or will help me train my
brain through curated sequences of fun
arcade style questions in logic,
linear Algebra,
classical mechanics,
artificial neural networks,
and more.
These modules test critical thinking and
analysis skills that could apply to the
real world.
And if you want to learn more about our
future overlords,
I'd recommend their module all machine
learning which breaks down how
supercomputer succeed in analyzing data.
We're humans fall short,
so develop your critical thinking and go
to brilliant.org/wise.
Crack to sign up for free.
The first 200 people that go to that
link will get 20 percent off the annual
premium subscription.
So what do you guys think?
Drop me a comment and let me know.
And as always,
piece.
That's how we sign off.